as record numbers of foreign nationals
pour
across our southern border many of them
unaccompanied
minors and as difficulties abound
amid this pandemic problem on problem on
problem
white house press secretary jenn saki
deflects any questions
she wants to talk about the past
administration and specifically
the morality problem that they had at
the border
you've been telling migrants from right
there for a month now all the way back
to february 10th
that now is not the time to come but
they are coming
in bigger numbers every day so do you
have a messaging problem
well i would say that in the last
administration we had a morality problem
and uh children were being pulled from
the arms of their parents
and kids were being sent back on a
treacherous journey and
that's not the approach of this
administration so certainly we
understand that means there will be more
kids who
are crossing the border we made a policy
decision that that was the right
humane step to take but i think it's
also important for people to understand
that the vast majority of people who
come
to our border are turned away are sent
back
uh to their countries what we're talking
about here are unaccompanied
children wait wait wait wait wait so the
problem is the last administration would
send a lot of people back and this is
very different
even though the biden administration is
going to send people back and the last
administration
ripped children away from their parents
and this administration
is ripping children away from their
parents and
the reason for this is they need to vet
everybody so they've already admitted to
that part
and the past administration with the
morality problem they were putting
kids in cages and the biden
administration okay sure it's
it's putting kids in cages but you know
they but they're being really
really nice about it i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
cricket scorezani who says jensaki has
the most difficult job in
america convincing everyone that the
emperor has clothes
that is what's going on and it is why i
feel for her you know if i had that job
it would be tough to get out of bed in
the morning it already is tough to get
out of bed
because i sleep on my pillow my pillow
makes the greatest pillows
ever period that's it that's it that's
all i know that a lot of people
have an affinity for my pillow because
they share the politics of my pillow you
know the company has been in the
political news
i would buy my pillow pillows if it were
a communist
company i'm so i'm not proud of that
fact it's just that they are
so good they don't go flat you can wash
and dry them as many times as you want
they maintain their shape they are made
in the usa if you do not have a my
pillow if you know someone who doesn't
now is the time to get one because for a
limited time my pillow's offering their
premium my pillows for their lowest
price ever
you can get a queen size premium my
pillow regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that's forty dollars in
savings
kings are only five dollars more
absolutely love it sleep on it every
night
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square there you will find not
only this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the geese of dream bed sheets
the my pillow mattress topper and the my
pillow towel sets
or call 800-651-1148 use promo code
dailywire go check out my pillow today
this is a prime example of the emperor
has no clothes
the bide administration by any measure
by the standards of the right and the
standards of the left
the immigration policies here are worse
than the trump administration's
immigration policies
the immigrant the effect on immigration
worse than
under the trump administration and
gensake has to say no well but it's
different
it's different this is i don't know if
you've seen that meme on the internet
of spider-man pointing at spider-man and
accusing one
that is what's happening here she's she
she
is trying to deflect from this obvious
point
that the immigration problem every
problem associated with it has gotten
much much worse under joe biden
and the way she deflects on this is she
says
well we have better morals better morals
well
what is her example of having better
morals she tries to dance around these
issues
but what we have seen from other biden
advisors and even from gensake in the
last few days
is in practice the biden administration
is doing
exactly the same stuff that the trump
administration did
they're just they're doing it worse
they're doing it less effectively but
they're they're doing the same policies
so
the morality can't be it can't have to
do with their actions
it just has to do with their speech just
has to do with the way that they're
talking about they're talking about
how we need to be generous to the
unaccompanied minors
and we're we have a heart and we're
being compassionate but in terms of what
they're actually doing
there's no difference this is something
actually that i talk about
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds that
one of the the the campaign of political
correctness
seeks to replace the old moral order
with new
speech codes replaces moral codes for
speech codes and so the emphasis goes
away from what you do
to what you say that's why they're
always policing every little syllable
that we say
taking focus off of what we actually do
now some biden advisors are a little
more honest than jen
saki national security council official
roberta jackson
is asked at the white house is this a
crisis
at the border and she doesn't want to
answer that question she doesn't want to
use the word crisis but she does
admit that the crisis is joe biden's
fault
first of all one of the things i think
is important is we've seen surges before
surges tend to respond to hope
and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent-up demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence but i certainly think
that
the idea that a more humane policy would
be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
but perhaps more importantly it
definitely drove smugglers
to express
disinformation to spread disinformation
about what was now possible
so this is a you got to give credit to
her
she's she realizes she's trying to dance
around it at the end
but you have to give credit to her for
the honesty they're saying is this
biden's fault she says well look
under trump they knew that the federal
government the illegal aliens knew that
the federal government
was going to do everything in its power
to turn them away
to make it more difficult for them to
violate our country's laws
and enter this country illegally so
what happens you you disincentivize the
illegal border crossings you get fewer
border crossings
under biden people respond to hope
in her words so biden comes in and he
says yeah man i'm giving amnesty to
11 million people 20 million people you
bet come on in we're a generous country
we're going to stop building the border
wall
we're going to stop enforcing much of
our immigration policy
i'm going to nominate people to these
positions who are pretty weak on
immigration
and guess what happens when you create
that incentive
more people are coming over surges
happen
every administration has these kinds of
surges but joe biden
specifically has created incentives to
encourage
more people to come on over here
it's a great admission now she then
tries to qualify that and she says
but also this the smugglers they've
now had an opportunity to spread
disinformation right so trying to take
the onus off of biden and put it more on
these
smugglers and coyotes and those sorts of
people but even in the way she explains
it she's showing
that the opportunity that the smugglers
had to spread the disinformation about
the new immigration policies
which is frankly i think just
information i don't think it's
disinformation i do think biden wants to
give a mass amnesty
but even the opportunity to spread that
kind of news
is coming from the biden administration
so you have it on the record watch that
video because
it's probably going to disappear at some
point in the near future
when the biden administration wises up
and realizes that this this woman has
admitted guilt
on their behalf joe biden himself
doesn't want to answer very many
questions at all he's now gone
i think 50 days something like 50 days
without a press conference
this is the longest stretch for a newly
inaugurated president
in modern history he's blowing his
competition out of the water
and he was asked about this at just a
quick little covid he was giving a
statement on kovid
he was not holding a press conference he
was asked about the press conference
pretends not to hear the questions
the surplus will he's
you don't need to hear the answer is
just it's kind of silly
but he hears these two questions being
shouted out he's kind of wandering away
where am i supposed to go he does this a
lot after he speaks
and he goes hey mr president what about
the surplus and he's like still kind of
wandering and we started listening and
then you're mr president when are you
going to hold a press conference
he stops he's like ah shoot it was
pretty loud
well you see the surplus and he just
ignores the question and pretends
that he did not hear it because he
doesn't have any good answers one
i don't i don't think he's capable
any longer of answering these difficult
questions under fire
a younger joe biden was a little better
at this because he's such a bs artist
but older joe biden i mean you see the
guy sort of puttering around
the oval office or around these
podiums it's a very sad thing to watch
so i don't think he's up for it but also
even if he were even if this guy were a
used car salesman
in in his prime he would not be able to
give serious answers to these questions
and to
the problems that he has created so joe
biden
not representing conservatives not
representing the majority of americans
who
don't like what's going on at the
southern border joe biden also not
representing very many people
in his own party there was a great clip
going around of some young
lib some young democrat guy who was on
cnn
and uh it was being asked about the
biden administration and what he thinks
of things and
all that kid wants to know is where is
his stimulus money at
young democrats like ben see a lot of
promises unkept
they're putting that stimulus track on
the back burner they're putting
the minimum wage hike on the back burner
and they're dropping bombs in cereal
right now and those bombs are kind of
expensive for a dude who owes me two
thousand dollars
that's a pretty good line the the
impulse behind it is fairly perverse
but the line is pretty good and and it
gets to
a criticism of biden that
many of us on the right have made which
is
that the old left-right divide is kind
of breaking down a little bit this is
why you hear
the term woke on the left and red pilled
on the right
is both of these terms represent sort of
waking up
out of a dream-like state and in in
this third political entity you have
what's called the uniparty you know some
people refer to it
as kind of the bush people and the biden
people and they're all kind of pursuing
the same foreign policy
and the joke of it is that you know
george bush is terrible he's a
conservative he's a nazi frankly
and then when obama and biden pursue his
exact same foreign policy
they will say well you know sure but a
woman released the bombs
yes but a gay muslim
transgender person was piloting the
drone
you know we had rainbow flags and blm
stickers
on all of the bombs that were being
dropped on the middle east so you see
it's very very different
it's the same sort of excuse that
gensake's giving saying no
yeah we're doing the same thing that
trump did but we we have good morals
you see you're doing the same thing what
are you talking about it's uh it's all
just sort of lipstick
on the pig of this consensus between
the established right and the
established left that people on the
left and right the more populist
elements are saying wait we don't want
that anymore at all we still disagree
with the left we still disagree with the
right
but but whatever this establishment
thing is we certainly don't want that
either when consensus breaks down when
stability breaks down often it's very
good to have physical assets
that's why i really like acre gold the
price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately now there is a way
to buy gold
through a company called acre that will
allow you to buy physical gold without
having to shell out all that money at
once acre will let you subscribe
to gold bars for as little as thirty
dollars a month
but michael gold bars cost more than
thirty dollars uh they do it's an
ingenious way to to allow more people to
invest in physical gold
you pay each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
just recently acre has introduced a new
100 a month subscription to a five gram
gold bar
they also you know there's an ammo
shortage right now so they've made a
solid gold
24 karat 9 millimeter bullet that you
can buy right now
can't find these anywhere they're only
making a thousand of them uh you can't
shoot it unless you're aiming at a
werewolf then then you can
but michael you don't you shoot gold
bullets at werewolves uh sounds like
you've never shot a werewolf
visit getacregoal.com michael and start
investing in physical gold today make
sure you go to
this url because acre is giving away a
gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is
getacregle.com michael thank you aker
gold for supporting the show
the old left right divide
is breaking down a little bit
the left right divide is not some
permanent
uh eternal uh sort of way to understand
politics the left right divide only
comes about
during the french revolution and it
refers to people who were sitting on the
left and
they were the radicals and the
revolutionaries and people who were
sitting on the right they were the more
conservative elements
they wanted to preserve the monarchy
they wanted to preserve hierarchy and
social order
so the way the way that we use left and
right it can kind of change
and circumstances change and the parties
change too
and there's some issues that bring this
up so there was recently a poll
out from a left-leaning pole source
that shows that most people
reject gender ideology
specifically with regard to girls sports
most people do not think that
men should be able to compete in girls
track meets and win their
prizes and win their scholarships
how is this the issue that unifies
people because if you think of all the
big issues facing the country
most people if you were just thinking
about it for two seconds you'd say
oh girls sports i don't know that's way
way down on the list that barely matters
at all
except it represents
so much of the rot that is at the heart
of our
entire politics the reason that
the transgender issue has been able to
kind of crack up
some of the left-wing consensus and has
has
aroused the passions of conservatives
is not because we particularly care
about women's sports i don't i don't
know that i've ever watched women's
sports for maybe the olympics are on
i'll say stuff but
very rarely it's because it's so
unjust and it's so obviously unjust
and it is so out of whack with reality
when you see some big hulking dude
running
circles around the little girls running
on the track court you just
know oh this isn't right
well you and then some egghead you know
liberal will say well no but actually
the way that the hormones in the body
and the way that this in the
the science shows and you say like no
sorry
you can give me whatever egghead
ridiculous cockamamie explanation you
want i just know that's not right
because you have all these very advanced
social theories that you are combining
with your social scientific theories to
give me some explanation
of why husky hank over there should be
allowed to compete against
all those little girls but i have two
eyes and i just know it's wrong
and i noticed that the guys keep winning
all the games so
it would seem that my two eyes are more
reliable than your ridiculous theories
among this uh the people surveyed 59
percent
support a ban of and the wording here is
key a ban
of uh biological males from competing
against
biological girls in female athletics 46
percent of women support a ban so it's
lower but
34 percent oppose a ban so far greater
percentage support the ban
among republicans it's about three to
one democrats 40 percent support a ban
42 percent oppose a ban so democrats
identified democrats are the only people
who slightly more oppose the ban
independence though it's overwhelming 49
support the ban 33 opposed gen z is
about evenly split
on this because they've been steeped in
gender theory and because they're young
and don't know what they're talking
about yet
millennials some millennials who are
often considered more liberal
more to the left in many ways than gen z
overwhelmingly support the ban
baby boomers roughly around the same
percentage actually they're a little
less likely to support the ban than
millennials so these numbers are
changing by generation but that might
change as people get older too
i also want to focus in here on the
wording of this of this uh
the coverage here so the coverage is is
referring to biological males and
biological girls i understand
why people do that i know a lot of
conservatives who do that too
but i think it's a bad idea i think it
is mistaken
i think it is giving in to political
correctness
there is no such thing as a biological
male
as distinct from a spiritual male or a
psychological male
there were just males there's just dudes
okay
and the reason people use this term
biological male is they want to be very
very precise and they want to make these
arguments from biology and they want to
say that actually
it's the physicality of the person and
the physicality is somehow different
than the soul or the spirit
and that is the transgender argument
when you
say the phrase biological male you are
making the transgender argument the
transgender argument
is that there is a difference between
one's biology
and one's other identity
and the transgender people say that this
other identity this metaphysical
identity that's my true identity and my
body has nothing to do with it
but when the right comes out and says
biological males or biological girls
they're just making the flip side of
that argument they're saying yeah
there's a difference between
your biological identity and your other
kind of identity or spiritual identity
whatever you want to call it
but your true identity is your
biological identity but the actual
conservative argument
is that we are not split between our
soul and our body they're not completely
separate entities
we are one entity the the
technical term for this is hylomorphic
beings right the body and the soul are
fused
where they're in they're inseparable on
earth and so it's you
when you when you divide it up even if
you're dividing it up to argue with the
left on the transgender question
you're actually giving them their
argument this is hate to plug my book
two times in a show but this actually is
kind of the argument here this is what
we do all the time on the right
is even when we think we're fighting
against the left when you think we're
fighting against political correctness
and locism and cancel culture
we're just giving in we're just giving
it in a sort of different way that we're
not even conscious of
we really ought to stop doing that
because i do think we're in a moment
of real political chaos and chaos breeds
opportunity
there are things that are shifting here
if you've got the majority of people
see with their own two eyes oh my gosh
wow look how crazy this is
this left wing ideology on gender is so
nuts what else
is nuts about their ideas this is a good
opportunity to grab it but we're not
going to win that
by acquiescing and giving in on an issue
that is overwhelmingly
in our favor because it's so clear
what this comes from is uh
you know this minor relatively trivial
issue of the girls sports
comes from this broader issue which is
that we no longer want to
admit some things are normal and some
things are abnormal
there are norms there are standards we
even on the right we don't want to admit
that we want to say well you do you you
do whatever you want you pursue your own
appetites and desires you
be free as though that's really what
freedom is it's not it's not even close
to freedom it's not what the founders
thought freedom was it's not what any
sophisticated people have thought
freedom is in our history but it comes
down to norms it comes down to standards
are you allowed to say this is normal
this is not we're not and i'll give you
a clear example of it
dove the soap the the company that makes
dove soap
is now removing the term normal from its
packaging because
they're referring to shampoo you know do
you have normal hair do you have some
particular hair condition
because normal is not inclusive enough
and they go further they say we know
that removing normal alone will not fix
the problem
but we believe it is an important step
toward a more
inclusive definition of beauty says
sonny jane the president of unilever's
beauty and personal care division which
includes
dove it's not inclusive
if i if i say it's normal to have all of
my appendages
right it's a normal that's that's the
norm that's how it's supposed to be
now some people are born with
deformities or they
suffer amputations or they have
disabilities and so there's something
abnormal
about their physique this is not a
reason to
be rude to somebody this is not a reason
to ostracize somebody from society
but likewise it is
simply insane it's it's simply not true
to say that it is normal if you got
uh 10 fingers and 10 toes that is the
norm that's the normal thing that's
how the body is supposed to be a lot of
people have nine fingers or 11 fingers
right now as a proportion of society not
a lot of people have that but
a lot of people in the world have that
and that is a deviation
from the norm the way that we can have
medical science is we know that there is
something that is normal we know there's
some way the body is supposed to behave
and then when things go awry that's how
you know okay there's a problem here
maybe we can treat it maybe we don't
have to treat it maybe it's benign but
it's
right if you don't admit that there's a
standard
you can't have any of that you can't
really have medical science
you can't have any kind of scientific
discussion you can't
really communicate at all because you're
not referring to some objective reality
that is in part why the the transgender
issue is so
at the top of our minds even though it
as a psychological matter it affects a
very few
a small number of people it is spreading
as a social contagion
but people who are really born with this
condition
who develop it in a way that that really
messes up their life very small number
of people
but the principle here is what the left
is after and it's why the left is so
focused on this
because the entire process of political
correctness woke-ism cancel culture
whatever you want to call it
is about upending the old norms
and if there are norms then you can't
you cannot succeed in having upended
those
one way to get a sense of
norms in your life is to recognize that
there is such a thing as beauty some
things are more beautiful
some things are less beautiful if you
want beauty in your home
highly recommend paint your life i
cannot possibly
overstate how impressed i am by
paintyourlife.com
you send them a photo maybe multiple
photos of a family member of a special
place
of a pet or something they will take
that and create
an actual hand-painted work of art
and i like the oil paintings they have
other options as well it makes a
terrific wedding gift i gave one to my
stepbrother but then i got one
for myself of a family member of mine
who had died
it is so beautiful i can't tell you how
impressed i am they work with you every
step of the way i was working on i don't
know about the background you got to
change this you got to change that
it's really unbelievable and that the
value the price is so
so good at paintyourlife.com there is no
risk if you don't love the final
painting
your money is refunded guaranteed right
now as a limited time offer
get 20 off your painting twenty percent
off and free shipping
to get the special offer text the word
michael to sixty four thousand that is
michael m i c h a
e l two sixty four thousand text michael
to sixty four thousand paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
term supply available at
paintyourlife.com
terms again text michael to 64 000.
where is this attack on norms
coming from because that's what this is
about
the gender ideology the law and order of
our country it is it is an attack
on norms we were promised with joe biden
we elect him we're gonna get the new
normal
we're gonna a return to normalcy well
yeah we're getting the new normal is
what we're getting
it's not normal at all it's coming from
an attack
on the metaphysical foundations of our
civilization there was a
guy in a turtleneck who went viral
on tick-tock the other day because he
was claiming
that jesus lord and redeemer
second person of the blessed trinity
is a racist take a listen did you know
that there's a part of the gospel of
mark where jesus uses
a racial slur in mark chapter 7 there's
the account of the seraphinian woman
a woman who is syrian and greek both of
which there were strong biases against
within the jewish community
and she comes to ask jesus to heal her
daughter who's possessed by a demon
and what is jesus's response he says
it's not good for me to give the
children's food meaning the children of
israel's food
to dogs he calls her a dog
what's amazing about this account is
that the woman doesn't back down
she speaks truth to power she confronts
jesus and says
well you can think that about me but
even dogs deserve the crumbs from the
table
her boldness and bravery to speak truth
to power actually changes jesus mind
jesus repents of his racism and extends
healing to this woman's daughter
i love this story because it's a
reminder that jesus is human he had
prejudices and bias
and when confronted with it he was
willing to do his work
and this woman was willing to stand up
and speak truth
is that what happened uh you know
i've read the same gospel account i
that's
not exactly what happened as far as i i
can tell
what happens of course is
something like what he described happens
and then christ
says it's not not fit to give this to
dogs
and she begs and she pleads and she says
in the gospel according to saint matthew
yes lord yet even the dogs eat the
crumbs that fall from their master's
table
then jesus answered her o woman great is
your faith
be it done for you as you desire and her
daughter was healed instantly
she did not change jesus's mind had
this young man going on to read the
gospel according to saint john
he would have known this because john
begins
very first lines by proclaiming that
christ is the divine logic of the
universe
logic itself the word of god
so you can't change christ's mind
because he is
logic he is the reason the fundamental
reason
that undergirds reality uh
now he does show to this woman and to
others
uh her faith and
uh he does uh show our brokenness
and his grace he does all of that this
wonderful this cause to be rejoicing
supposed to say yes oh my gosh i can't
believe it i
miserable sinner me i will say with such
gratitude that i have been redeemed
through really no uh
help of my own other than uh responding
to god's grace with an act of faith
god comes to me like christ was near
this woman and
she responds to that in an act of faith
and he says oh great great is your faith
be it done as you desire
or you can say god is a racist
those are the two options the the one
option will save your soul and our
entire civilization
and built our entire civilization the
other option
does really well on tick-tock and
our culture seems to be choosing the
latter there are two particular heresies
here that this guy is espousing and the
reason i
mention it is because it it pervades our
political culture
the heresies are arianism which denies
the divinity of christ
there's a very famous account from the
council of nicaea where saint nicholas
santa claus
punches the arch-heretic arius in the
face
because he doesn't want to take it no
more and and the other
the other heresy is pelagianism the idea
that this woman earned her salvation
that you can earn your your salvation
through works which sometimes
certain protestant denominations accuse
the catholic church of doing but
that's just not true the catholic church
condemned the heresy of pelagius
many many moons ago these are heresies
that have infected our modern culture we
deny
divinity we deny the divinity of christ
undergirding our civilization and also
we're really impressed with ourselves
and we think that we can save ourselves
this is the motivating principle behind
communism
behind so many of our modern ideologies
and it's
it uh also speaks to our pride that we
uh
have now used to be considered the queen
of all vices now it's elevated as such a
high virtue that we have
parades dedicated to pride
speaking of actual issues with women i
have to touch on andrew cuomo here
cuomo is being accused of aggressively
groping a woman
so you know this has been trickling out
again and again first a woman said he
kind of looked at me wrong
then then it was said there was some
video that cuomo gave a hot dog to a
reporter
and the reporter said no it was totally
fine it wasn't lecherous at all and they
said no it's sexual harassment
then he kissed somebody maybe then he
looked at someone the wrong way again
now he's being accused of aggressively
groping
some woman why are these trickling out
so steadily so gradually
as they are because i don't really take
this
scandal all that seriously seems pretty
contrived to me
the real scandal as we have been
pointing out on the show from the minute
these
these uh accusations started to break
the real scandal is covid
democrats don't want to talk about it
they want to push this guy to the side
for a reason that they won't really have
to answer for right this sort of
sexism or something like that that
is maybe going to work you know cuomo's
on the ropes though i have said
don't count this guy out from the very
beginning when everyone said he's
completely dead
do not count this guy out this guy is a
fighter he's a survivor he's been a
political animal his whole life
i think he's really bad for the state of
new york and i say this as
having been one of his constituents i
was his waiter one time
i i guess i actually have a couple funny
andrew cuomo stories
i don't think he's good for new york but
i do
i do have a grudging respect for him and
i don't know that you can count him out
yet and that's why he's going to force
the issue
on impeachment he's not not going to
resign
because there's this morality play it
goes right back to what we're talking
about with jen saki
they're trying to take the moral high
ground by talking about some contrived
sex thing where's the morality on the
nursing homes where's the morality on
the actual kovid response where's the
morality
more broadly the democratic governors
were the worst on covet
republican governors did the best on
covet look at cuomo
look at desantis
where is the real morality or is it all
just words words words
you know speaking of great words you got
to check out
drew clavin's book the final installment
in another kingdom
i really think the world would be a much
better place and your lives would all be
much better all of our lives would be
much better if we made more time
to read books rather than just scroll
all the time this is something that i
struggle with myself
well got a great recommendation for you
the new york times bestselling author
and renowned podcast host
andrew clavin has this latest and final
book in the another kingdom series
the emperor's sword it's now available
for purchase online
the it's really superb i have been
involved intimately
in another kingdom since the beginning
because i
have voiced all of the characters on the
podcast that's how we first released it
before there was a physical book before
there were audio books
we did the podcast it jumped up the
charts we continued the second season
and the third i've gotten to voice it
the whole way the books get better as
they go first one i think is really
terrific
the third one is the best uh
you you can also get the audio book and
you can listen to your very favorite
podcast host voicing that as well not
just the podcast but also the audiobook
go check it out also you heard us
announce on election night
now the wait is over candace owens is
premiering her new daily wire show
candace
candice is also known for being a
founder of the blexit foundation which
looks to change the narrative
surrounding america's minority
communities
not to mention she is the author of the
new york times bestseller blackout
how black america can make its second
escape from the democrat plantation
join candace every week as she covers a
host of different topics from the latest
trends
to hard-hitting news get to know the
real candace funny authentic
and insightful find out why the left
loves to hate her by going to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25
off i sat down with my friend candace
owens just couple days ago
to talk about her new show everything
that's in the news
take a listen
i am joined now by my friend candace
owens candace
i can't help but notice you are a woman
you're black a woman of color a woman
sorry woman of color you are
famous you are american
you married a brit and yet
you turned out great what was your
secret and where did meghan markle go
wrong meghan markle went wrong a lot of
ways uh
first and foremost she is a hollywood
leftist that's all you need to know you
know what i mean
and this story this whole everyone was
like you know why did you get into this
like why is this get you know really get
under your skin
because i married an englishman you know
my husband's father was in the house of
lords
and it was that that's like like being a
mechanic or something i don't know is
that like
an electrician shop
and so it was definitely a learning
curve for me even when i met my husband
going to england and there's just like
different sets of rules their society is
very traditional
and i was just i loved it you know i
loved stepping into someone's culture
and not trying to change it
and this is the thing about the left
that drives me crazy is that they just
have no appreciation for tradition they
have no appreciation for history it's
why they think that
everything between los angeles and new
york needs to be
is backwards right right and yeah the
flyover right it needs a makeover
um and for her to just do that to go to
this country with all of their
traditions and
the queen of course being so significant
the meaning of her
just to have been sitting on the throne
for that long and having
uh yes and she has seen the country
through so much
and to do what they did just cheapen
that and say well
it's racism this is the reason we had to
leave it's racism meghan markle
look black to you did anybody look at
her and say oh harry's dating a black
woman
my mother seriously my sicilian mother
was much darker
than meghan markle you would you would
have no idea she has that thing in
hollywood they call it
ethnically ambiguous right you can play
sort of any role
she could have played an indian woman in
films she could have said that she she
could have said she was mixed race i
would have bought that she could have
definitely said she was italian
she has freckles you know you could just
think that you know it's completely
obscure and yet she she's like you know
i'm less than 25
black but i've realized that because i'm
getting bad press i can say the bad
process because
i'm less than 25 black because there is
this purity test every time they write a
hit piece they say well
is there any black in this person well
that's the reason we're gonna we're
gonna write a horrible piece about them
and especially being me because i have a
public profile and as you know
they have written so many backgrounds
nice things
like that time they accused me of a
mosque mosque shooting in new zealand
that's right they've never been to new
zealand i don't even write about mosques
or muslims or anything but they were
like candace did this i woke up
worldwide news i had people in france
like in china
and people were asking me for comments
everywhere and i don't think i have ever
once said this bad press
is because i'm black so it's just it's
such a
there's a cowardice well and it's such
an excuse i said there's a great
headline in the babylon b
said meghan markle inspires millions of
girls by showing that no matter how rich
beautiful and famous you are you too can
be oppressed right you know
she's oppressed and she's sitting across
from oprah you know what i mean and
she's they've been living in a actually
i think at some point they were at tyler
perry's 100 million dollar home
somewhere
flying on his planes and you really want
me to buy that you were chased out of
the country because
i guess you were less than 25 black and
then the richest part of the story
is them claiming that archie wasn't
given a title because he was black
has anyone seen a picture of archie and
i say this seriously if you believe
that archie suffered anti-black racism
then i'm a nigerian prince and i just
need your credit card details
and uh you're going to see that just
look at the picture stranded island
this you know i'm so glad to hear this
is your take on this because i have to
say i was a little frustrated i
understood it but i was frustrated
with the conservative reaction to this
which is who cares about the royal
family
i stopped caring about them in 1776. to
me that argument
falls flat because the royal family
represents this long conservative
tradition in the united kingdom and to
me i think the reason the meghan markle
story has really
got you excited kind of excited a lot of
us is because it's this awful
sort of modern millennial idea that
everything in the past is bad right
wicked and racist is the word for that
and i no matter what privileges i have
we all are so privileged
i am actually a victim and you all need
to feel bad for me
and the minute that i can't do exactly
what i want to do
this woman chose to marry into the royal
family it's not like it was a blind date
right it's not like on the third date
harry said oh you know darling i have
something i have to tell you
i haven't told you about my job yet but
uh you know she didn't it's not as
though she thought his first name were
prince you know like a musician right
she knows who he is and she chose to do
this
oh you know what's up she said she never
googled him i don't know they got
when he got down on one knee that's when
she was like oh my gosh she's a prince
wow she found out it was princess
diana's and even that is so absurd
michael i google everyone yeah i'll get
in the car as an uber driver and i'll be
like what's your name
just check this back around here make
sure you're gonna tell me on a date and
you didn't google you didn't linkedin
profile this is what we do okay
and especially her who a big piece of
story that's missing
she went to the uk with the intention of
marrying up she had a pr person who
wrote an entire piece
she hired a public relations firm to try
to get
um to start dating a football player so
that was her thing she was like
okay they found a football player
exactly and she lands on a prince and
you know piers morgan who i really can't
stand
but he talks about how he reached out to
her and she kept saying she wanted to
get involved in the circles because it
just wasn't working for her in america
it wasn't working for her in canada so
she was like okay let me try let me try
england but
she had no idea who prince harry or
prince william or kate middleton she
just missed that whole thing
right um she just was there what are the
odds yeah what are the
see what you described herself as
because we should talk about that
i didn't watch the interview but she
said she felt like the little mermaid
who fell in love with the prince
and lost her voice if only i know if
only i mean
i'm just trying to think of this a
straight face like she did let me try
i felt like you know the little mermaid
who
went over and found a prince and fell in
love and
lost my voice it's just as believable as
she says you say this on
air of course my favorite part is she's
saying these sorts of things
occasionally harry would try to well you
notice
get out of here harry stop it don't
listen to it listen
camera on me folks oh she's so
unbearable and yeah
i'm glad you brought the fact that a lot
of conservatives were so dismissive
i hate that because you know we so often
talk about how the left is
ignorant right to not try to understand
what it is about the royals that is so
significant it is not just like
oh i'll praise them because they're
kings and queens and princesses it
really isn't about that what they
represent
um is is history right and that is what
they love about them is that these
people they never issue political
statements they don't just go where the
wind blows
and there is something about americans
even the conservative americans
that we have the strain of progressivism
because look our country was built on
that right we were built on kind of
tearing down traditions and sometimes
yes
traditions need to be torn down um but
where we're at today where you have no
appreciation for anything
and that is why hashtag abolish you know
which they're so dumb they're like
abolish the monarchy as if the monarchy
has any power
anymore but um and they actually abolish
the royal family is where we're at
because they just want everything torn
down
newer faster and they want the world to
look like whatever hollywood
um singers and actresses think that it
ought to look this was it
it's sort of this woman seemed that
she wanted to play a disney princess
more than she wanted to be
an actual princess and and how true is
that of so much of our society you know
edmund burke the great conservative
philosopher his big distinction
between the american revolution the
french revolution was that the american
revolution
was kind of conservative it didn't
destroy everything right whereas the
french revolution really did destroy
everything
and so there was always this sense in
america that we want to really
we want to be the real thing you know we
there is a there is a kind of
tradition here and uh we didn't we
didn't want to become this really
shallow abstracted culture that
unfortunately it seems
like we're becoming right and you know
you hear so often from conservatives
we need to take back the culture we need
to fight back in the culture well
you know in order to do that we're going
to need to get really serious and we're
not we're going to have to start saying
like
no right don't do that that's a that is
a bad thing
you know we need to defend an older set
of standards
right i think too often um we meet
people in the middle and
and it's such an easy game there's wait
there's actually an expression
that you used to talk about when it what
is the overton theory right over to
windows yeah exactly what's exactly what
left is doing it's brilliant right
they're just they say something so
extreme like
here we are and and they say something
so extreme
that they're like men can give birth
yeah i'm like no they can't no they
can't but eventually we say okay please
don't say that we'll meet you halfway
and now we're inching closer to where
they are you know how we do this we
always we always say look
men men can't give birth right men are
not women but then we start edging in
this way when we'll start saying
so and so is a biological male right and
it's like no it's just
he's just a man he's just a man he's not
like he's not like a psychological woman
but
it's just right it's just one thing
right because we start to be
conciliatory
guess what you look up 10 years later
and you're way
and that's what's happened that's
literally what's happened especially in
this last decade is that we just keep
meeting them halfway
but the halfway is also it's always
moving towards their ridiculously far
left point and i think that there needs
to be more
people say to me okay you're so far
right i'm like actually i'm just right
right i'm just right i'm actually almost
in the middle yes because you guys have
gone so crazy
10 years ago you would have been
considered centrist
human being like you know when we
accepted that men and
women were men and women and now you're
actually being called a bigot i mean
yesterday
international women's day the aclu
tweets
about saying you know trans women are
women on international women's day
you said men are women the patriarchy is
striking
the trans woman it means man right this
is a different word for man so you just
tweeted out
in order to celebrate women let me tell
you how much men can be women you know
you're being modest here and this is
actually something i'm very excited for
about your show
canvas right which is launching is that
you
right you're just saying sort of normal
thing i don't i don't think anything
you're saying is extreme
but most people do not have the cojones
to do it
talking about men and women right most
people don't have the guts to do it
and you i don't know what it is because
we've been friends for years you know i
i remember you back in the
in the old timey days on youtube and
you more than just about anybody have
been
able to withstand this onslaught from
the left
and throw it back in their face and not
let them cancel you and it's really
i i don't know how you've done it i just
hope that i show people that there's no
consequence
you know for telling the truth and you
just just say it say it again
say it again say it again they can only
cancel you so many times like once they
went to
once i survived like being accused of a
mosque shooting in new zealand i was
like okay well where do we go from
what else are you gonna accuse me of
here right that's great um and so
i think that i've just bounced back and
i've been unapologetic which is the most
important thing
don't say sorry don't say sorry because
once you start saying sorry to the left
you will never stop saying sorry to the
left right because it's not about
them need an apology they need they want
pure capitulation they want to make sure
you capitulate to everything they say
what they're seeking actually
is their own kind of monarchy right like
they're they're seeking to rule over you
your opinions your ideas and their
establishments
exactly that is their established church
they seek for you to be their peasants
and the second you say sorrow you become
that well this is
to say don't say sorry speaking of the
church i mean this is something i've
really struggled with i think you're
completely right
but look as a christian i want to
apologize when i feel i've done
something wrong i have no problem doing
that
to oh miserable sinner that i am i i
really don't mind it
except i know that's not really what it
is that's not when you
apologize to the left it's not first of
all they're not seeking that in good
faith it's beating a dog into submission
yes
that is that is what it is it's sort of
uh it's unfortunate because i'd i'd love
to be in a society where i say oh yeah
maybe i shouldn't have said that sorry
yeah exactly and you know it's funny
because i did an interview the other day
and they said
to me sort of preparation for the show
like is there anything that you look
back on
in the past that you that you're sorry
for like things that you've tweeted and
things of that nature and i said
no and i said because i want to give
permission to people that are following
me to know that you're allowed to change
your mind
yeah remember this thing where we used
to grow up like you know a long time ago
i used to think barbies were the coolest
thing and then all
day society should be run by us playing
barbies in the room that was candace at
four years old
am i allowed to evolve from that
position without apologizing for my
passion i love it you know
people throw this at you a lot they'll
say you used to be left-wing but now
you're conservative
i got you yeah i got a couple of brain
cells i opened a book
you know what i mean i opened a book and
i'm like it's just so ridiculous and
what what is so alarming about that sort
of a culture like forget us like we're
adults we're old we have kids now right
we're old man we're old people i'm again
i'm trying to get fat but
i'm already old i want to be older think
about kids how hard it is to be a kid
today
when you are being told that if you make
a mistake you're done you're over you're
canceled
you know you say one wrong thing when i
was a kid we didn't have twitter
facebook instagram so i could just be a
crappy human being for one day and say
horrible things and the next day be like
oh you know that didn't feel too good i
want to be someone different today
and i was allowed to go that's what
growing up is you learn because you do
things wrong even toddlers
they're violent toddlers they're
throwing things down you know violent
human beings they think through things
and they just they choose violence every
day toddlers right even my cute little
newborn you know
he he'll throw punches at him yeah same
thing and it's like now velep is like
you
are exactly who you are when you are two
is when you are four candace won
candace three years ago in politics i've
pretty much grown up politically
publicly right you know has to you know
make apologies or make amends no
if i said it then i meant it then but if
i've transformed my opinion here's why
this is what it looks like
grow up right that's right that's right
that you you know what if
if i had social media when i was 11 or
12
canceled could you yeah could you
imagine the show right now is there
forever
but i love it because it takes a lot of
gumption to be able to say yeah
i thought this thing a few years ago
yeah and now guess what i've matured
i've
educated myself maybe that's something
we can all do as a culture as well you
know one great way people can do that
tuning in to candace i can't wait it's
going to be fabulous i'm so excited
i'll be issuing tons of non-apologies
when people are offended i will the next
day i mean even seeing that tale in
between the legs copy and pasted apology
that so many people do like you know
like they say one thing and then it's
suddenly like the next day on their show
they're like you know
you know i want to apologize for some
things that i said that made perfect
sense but i
i hear you that you're offended so
therefore uh we're all growing and it's
just like
never just say i'm sorry you were
offended yeah and
maybe don't watch my show there have
been a few times where there's been a
lot of pressure to give the apology and
i think there's an old sicilian
expression
just a little yeah look underneath your
chin that's what i think about it
uh my dear i can't wait for the show to
start everybody's got to tune in and
watch it
candace on the daily wire i will be
eagerly watching it just from right
across the way
and i'll i'll see you around the office
water cooler
love it
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you